[Aplausos]
ah
[Música]
tanto
ah
[Música]
[Aplausos]
en la piel de un joven que va
actualmente a un concierto de música
clásica que nos encontramos en primer
lugar la información que hemos recibido
acerca del concierto es escueta
básicamente el nombre del director el
nombre de la orquesta y el del
repertorio que se va a interpretar la
sala magnífica pero neutra igual para
todos los conciertos el público en
general mayor vestido de gala como para
la ocasión la orquesta vestida de negro
formada por músicos fantásticos pero los
cuales no conocemos ni tendremos el
placer de conocer después del concierto
y el propio evento en sí dos horas de
música maravillosa estructuradas en las
ya típicas dos partes con un repertorio
poco variado pero casi fantástico que de
ver pegado a mi butaca sin casi poder
respirar
simplemente aplaudiendo cuando está
estipulado sin poder expresar las
emociones que realmente me está
transmitiendo esta música
termina el concierto y volvemos a casa
qué hay de atractivo en todo esto la
música por supuesto pero para un joven
no entendido de clásica le supone mucha
diferencia quedarse en casa viendo el
concierto a través de youtube y entonces
toma un refresco de cola y pudiendo
levantarse aplaudir o bailar al son de
la música
los jóvenes estamos acostumbrados cada
vez más a un mundo dinámico con eventos
de todo tipo donde interactuar el
sentirse parte del evento es fundamental
y esto no pasa actualmente en los
conciertos de música clásica y es por
esto que cada vez vemos menos jóvenes en
los auditorios que rondan una media de
edad de 60 años asociando por ende este
tipo de música algo aburrido serio que
no nos gusta de hecho muchos jóvenes
simplemente al escuchar el binomio
música clásica sufren como una especie
de reacción alérgica y dicen no esto no
es para mí pero qué pasa si toco esto
[Música]
seguro que muchos de vosotros esta
melodía o resulta familiar incluso
algunos os habrá emocionado al rememorar
aquellos tiempos cuando el niño de niños
veis la serie érase una vez el hombre
pero quién se ha parado a pensar que
esto es música clásica quién se ha
parado a pensar que este es el segundo
movimiento de la sonata número 20 de
ludwig van beethoven nadie quizás no ha
sido necesario analizar su contenido ni
escudriña su significado
simplemente nos gusta como una buena
película de tarantino un bocata de jamón
serrano
y además seguramente apetecería volver a
escucharla pero si yo hubiera comenzado
hola buenos días tengo interpretar
música clásica muchos de vos de haber
dicho mejor otro día pero no es que
solamente os guste ahora conozcáis sino
que os la sabéis y para ello vamos a
realizar aquí todos juntos un pequeño
experimento y vamos a formar el nuevo
coro te des jude valladolid formado por
todos nosotros
de manera que voy a tocar cuatro notas
al piano y necesito que vosotros me
respondas con las siguientes no pasa
nada si desafiamos un poco es normal
pero ante todo necesito energía en
vuestro canto vale
a
no
[Música]
fantástico nos la sabéis ahora una
pregunta cuántos de vosotros la habéis
visto en directo
veo que pocos como es posible que la
conozcáis sin haber escuchar el directo
y es más cómo es posible que os guste
tanto como para conocerla y no hayáis
ido a verlo en directo
eso mismo nos preguntábamos un grupo de
jóvenes que llegamos a madrid a estudiar
diferentes carreras universitarias y
veíamos como no había nada para que
pudiéramos continuar con la música al
mismo tiempo que los estudios y al mismo
tiempo veíamos como nuestros amigos y
compañeros rechazaron la clásica
simplemente por el nombre y eso no podía
ser entonces decidimos crear la joven
orquesta de estudiantes y colegios
mayores una orquesta que nos sirviera en
primer lugar poder continuar nuestra
pasión y al mismo tiempo tenemos claro
desde el inicio que teníamos que innovar
que llegar a los jóvenes que vivir a
nuestros conciertos y llegar a la mar la
clásica al menos tanto como nosotros y
no solo la clásica sino la música en
general pues a un buen músico cualquier
música le gusta siempre que sea buena
de esta manera comenzamos la andanza
siete locos de hecho al principio no
teníamos ningún violín nuestro único
violín era una flauta travesera pero aún
así estábamos convencidos de que si
nosotros estábamos allí habría más gente
en nuestra misma situación solamente
había que dar con ella y a través de
herramientas que tenemos al alcance de
nuestras manos
podríamos llegar a estos jóvenes y
cambiar el discurso de este joven que va
a un concierto de música clásica
ya la forma de afrontarlo de ser
completamente diferente el propio cartel
de promoción te ha de generar ganas de
que llegue el momento que ha de
transmitir que en esas dos horas va a
salir una experiencia completamente
diferente
la orquesta ataviada elegante pero no
formal son en gran parte amigos del
público y si no ya tendrá la ocasión de
conocerles
después en el photocall o en las cañas o
cena que se pueda montar para compartir
la experiencia el repertorio
fundamental se va desvelando a lo largo
de las dos semanas anteriores a través
de las redes sociales pero siempre con
un factor sorpresa para emocionar al
público
además estructurado en tres pilares
fundamentales el primero las bandas
sonoras música que a todos nos encanta
de las series y películas que vemos a
diario y que siempre nos gustaría ver en
directo por una orquesta en segundo
lugar el repertorio clásico sinfonías
conciertos pero presentadas tal y como
son por ejemplo se imaginan a mozart
tocando esto serio
[Música]
por supuesto que no
y el tercer pilar el estreno de obras de
compositores jóvenes españoles porque
ellos son el presente y el futuro de la
música clásica
y el propio concierto puede servir para
aprender disfrutar y al mismo tiempo
tener experiencias que no puedas tener
en ningún sitio más allá de ese
escenario
por ejemplo sentarte entre la orquesta y
ver el concierto desde un punto de vista
diferente o incluso subir y dirigir al
público o es más dirigir a la orquesta
no es emocionante poder enfrentarte una
orquesta y además porque no también al
mismo tiempo que suena la música que
haya un pintor o un escultor que plasme
la música en su obra no sería genial y
además compartir todo esto a través de
las redes sociales que los jóvenes
puedan publicar fotos videos para que
llegue a más jóvenes que era un posible
al concierto y vean como un concierto de
clásica puede llegar a molar
por tanto el objetivo es generar una
experiencia alrededor de la música
clásica que además nos sirva para
aprender pues cuanto más sabemos de algo
más nos gusta y esto podría trasladarse
a los colegios y los institutos donde
cada vez se apuesta menos por el arte la
cultura y el pensar y porque no podría
pasar como el alemán ya que además de
tener un equipo de fútbol tuviéramos una
orquesta por cada escuela
hay una frase maravillosa que veremos
después primero que contar una
experiencia una anécdota fue con rajoy
com vamos a dar un concierto en la
cafetería de mi colegio mayor era
domingo por la tarde y jugaba el real
madrid de casualidad entonces nosotros
teníamos que colocar el escenario
ensayar y había un hombre que siempre
viene ver todos los partidos la
cafetería que en cuanto le quitamos la
pantalla dijo bueno aquí me quitan estos
y dijimos bueno no pasa nada te dejamos
una pequeña pantalla para que pueda
seguir viendo el partido pero nosotros
tenemos que montar allí el escenario ya
me desentendí y seguí montando el
concierto y comenzamos el concierto el
concepto fue fantástico como ven una
cafetería llena de jóvenes emocionados
con la música clásica habíamos tocado la
primera sinfonía de beethoven la banda
sonora del juego de tronos o incluso una
obra de un compositor español juan
antonio simarro el mismo que
interpretado en la primera pieza
y cuál fue mi sorpresa cuando al final
en ese mismo escenario
todos juntos organizamos una acera para
compartir las experiencias y de repente
me encuentro a este señor que viene a
casa a cambiarse ya su hija pequeña al
lado ambos emocionados y dándome las
gracias por hacerles llegar la música de
una manera tan diferente la frase a la
que me referí anteriormente es esta y es
preciosa editor hugo dice la música
llega expresa aquello que no pueden las
palabras
y
ah
[Música]
[Aplausos]
a quien no le gusta un clásico pues bien
actualmente la juego la formamos 70
músicos de 35 carreras diferentes y de
25 puntos del mundo que nos reunimos
todos los viernes para compartir nuestra
pasión la música y gracias a estas
pequeñas herramientas hemos conseguido
llegar auditorios y cafeterías de gente
joven que sale emocionada queriendo
volver a un concierto de música clásica
y sobre todo convencidos de que la
clásica no es clásica muchas gracias
[Aplausos]